هنا في منطقه الزبير غرب مدينه البصره حيث
مضيف الشيخ كاظم الصرايفي الذي بات من
اشهر الاماكن التي تستقبل وفوده ومشجعين
خليجي 25 اضافه الى سفراء دول الخليج
العربي
في هذه الخيمه وبين دلال القهوه العربيه
الممزوجه بالهيل العراقي استقبل هذا الرجل
البصري سفير المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العراق عبد العزيز الشمري الذي حرص على
تلبيه دعوته امبارح كان استقبالنا في
المطار استقبال رائع من قبل المسؤولين
الحكوميين
بعد ما طلعنا من مطار استقبلنا الجمهور
العراقي استقبل الفريق السعودي بمواكب
واعلام همم الى فندق الشهره
اللي شفناه يثلج الصدر همم شيء مو غريب
على اهل البصره مو غريب على اهل العراق
كاظم السرافي همم ديوانه مفتوح وبيته
مفتوح وقلوبهم مفتوح لكل همم
المشاركين في بطوله خليجي 25 من دول مجلس
التعاون فاحنا عند اهلنا وما هو غريبه
عليهم الكرم ولا هو غريب عليهم
رحابه الصدر اليوم اييه من القرائب الامام
الرقبل سعاده السفير اجا بروحه بسيارته من
فندق الشيراتون الى الزبير مسافه 20 او 25
كيلو
دلاله على ذلك يدل على الامان والمحبه
محبه اهل البصره اخوتهم الخليج
احتضان البصره لاحتضان اخوتهم الخليج
اليوم تشوف عندي اخوه اشقاء من الكويت بس
طرشت لهم اللوكيشن رجعوا للمضيف نظيف
لم يتوقف عن استقبال ضيوفه من كافه دول
الخليج العربي الذين فضلوا النزول عنده
الاستمتاع بكل ما هو عربي مصري من اجواء
رحت
للخليجيه ان ان ان ان البصره افضل وان
الامان موجود والحمد لله واحنا والله يعني
نشكرهم على حسن الاستقبال ونشكرهم على ما
شاء الله وتبارك الرحمن على هذه الحفاوه
وعلى هذه الجمعه الطيبه
تفوقت المضاعف العربيه هنا على افخم
الفنادق في البصره حيث وجد ابناء الخليج
فيها القلوب مفتوحه قبل الابواب
من البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه